i haven't even thought about this in a
million years but you were talking about
aubry about people that uh
don't seem to care or don't have uh the
uh enthusiasm for wondering all in the
world
yeah i can remember that i used to be
for years i struggled like that where i
was
bored with things i was bored with
myself
i i was beating my brains out saying why
don't i love something what it what's
what is missing
and i my sort of my conclusion
was that i really did have
tremendous ambition and tremendous
aspiration
but i had buried it under layers of fear
you know as if if i would ever admit to
myself that i
wanted to be excellent at something that
that would be more than i could i could
take failure would be more than i could
take
and so when i finally sort of admitted
to myself and actually it's in the
authentic swing i think or maybe
something
but when i admitted to myself that i did
have ambition
i did want to do something suddenly
everything changed and then enthusiasm
did come but it was
fear so i i think when we
when we're running into people that are
not don't have enthusiasm don't have
that fire
i don't believe it's not there i think
it's buried under fear
and i think uh i think that's why great
teachers
coaches will put
a young person in a position where it
can they can exceed their expectations
or their belief
about themselves where they thought they
couldn't do it and then the guy kicks
them in the ass enough time they
actually do it and they go wow how did
that happen you know
and then that's the spark that can then
burst into flame if it's if it's guided
properly
and i see i see that everywhere i'm
sorry to say you know in this country
it's everywhere
well i'm glad that you brought up that
it was you at one point
and you you passed it because one of the
really important things about your book
i think is that you
your really objective assessment
assessment of your own life
at one point in time when you were like
40 years old you know you were talking
about this
that was a long time ago yeah this
script that wasn't you know
working and you know you know you know
you were like what the [ __ ] am i doing
and then
how did you go from that to completely
getting it together enough to write
these
books about getting it together how to
get it how'd you get over that fear
uh i think at that time
you mean the fear that i was just
talking about well the same thing yeah
how did you
how did you figure it out i think once i
realized
that i that there was something i wanted
that i wanted to be a writer
which i had refused to admit to myself
because i was so afraid of failing at it
then i just sort of said well you know
there was a moment it's actually in the
war of art
where i just sort of realized the way
you get there
is one step at a time you know like an
alcoholic
you know one one day at a time and that
it was
a a a process
that could be demystified it wasn't airy
fairy waiting for inspiration
it was just sit the [ __ ] down put a
piece of paper in a typewriter and start
you know and then do that the next day
and do it the next day and
when and the other aspect for me was
i had no choice that anytime i would try
to stop
and try to sell out i was like so
depressed
that i that so i just had no choice to
just keep going going going
but it was before i wrote the war of art
i probably had been writing for at least
30 years or at least
trying to do that that book came out in
about two months
just because it was so clear in my mind
that that's what i had been fighting all
these years did you find that
putting it down on paper helped you very
much because it became very clear to me
like a law almost yeah i mean for me you
know it's like